[Musique]
ces invitations à des conversations
groupe et elle inonde nos messageries
sur les réseaux sociaux on à madame
micheline de la fosse
on a un autre profil avec une dame qui
va s'appeler yolande à curtis derrière
yolanda il n'y a probablement pas une
fan aussi sexy que sur la photo que
c'est une évidence on a des opérateurs
on est vraiment des gens qui sont
derrière des ordinateurs et qui toute la
journée vont gérer ce qu'on appelle des
fermes de bottes et qui sont payés au
jour le jour pour ingérer ces profils
l'anneau sexe sur internet ça marche
plutôt pas mal et c'est une constante
qu'on retrouve sur beaucoup de réseaux
sociaux ça permet d'accrocher l'oeil à
l'utilisateur masculin ou féminin qui va
et qui va voir ce message là et ça va
retenir son attention des profils comme
celui de micheline ou de yolanda
il en existe des dizaines de milliers
sur internet derrière certains d'entre
eux se cachent des bottes des logiciels
conçus par des humains pour effectuer
des tests automatiques c'est vraiment un
profil qui est vide et qui ne sert ici
que pour envoyer un lien sur une
conversation groupe et en espérant que
l'un des participants de la conversation
appuyé sur ce bien vous cliquez sur le
lien vous savez pas vraiment que ça vous
en règle générale ces cds site
effectivement à caractère pornographique
sachant que c'est avec beaucoup droit
direction vous allez cliquer sur un lien
qui va vous amener sur un autre qui va
vous amener sur un autre et vous allez
vous retrouver sur un site internet
lambda parfois vous pouvez cliquer deux
fois sont de même le même lien et vous
allez vous retrouver sur deux sites
différents
c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement
important de pas cliquer sur c'est bien
là qu'est ce que vous avez aucune idée
du site final vous avais aucune idée de
ce qui va se passer sur ce site là et du
contenu qui va vous est présenté le
motif c'est toujours c'est toujours le
même si souvent l'argent l'argent et
l'influencé donc ici en fait on a on a
des gens qui sont des professionnels
réellement si elle devient une
profession c'est faux profils peuvent
être mobilisées pour plein de raisons
différentes
ça peut être pour faire la promotion
d'un site internet ça peut être pour
améliorer leurs effets
lancement d'un site internet ça peut
être pour de la désinformation on l'a vu
énormément sur ces dernières élections
américaines on va le voir dans les
élections à venir française on est sur
une activité aujourd'hui qui est
complètement est licite c'est c'est
contre les termes et conditions des
plateformes et ça va vraiment ça vient
vraiment polluer l'espace public qui
sont que sont les réseaux sociaux et le
débat public sur les réseaux sociaux
donc il faut vraiment signaler ses
comptes
il faut les reporter de manière à ce que
si vous avez les bons réflexes et vous
vous ne cliquez pas sur le lien peut
être quelqu'un d'autre peut-être n'aura
pas le bon réflexe donc signalé ses
comptes la reporter les est bloqué ses
comptes comme ça vous faites en plus une
bonne action pour 20 pour tout le monde